i believe you have a friend someone very
special to you that we're about to meet
you i do um allow me
to introduce you to martini
oh my goodness i'm very excited to see
martini in person i've seen her
on your instagram and we would love
to celebrate martini by asking you we
have a
a little thing we do here uh where we
ask rapid fire questions about
her in a game called martini in a minute
oh my god
are you in i'm so in let's go all right
here we go
start the clock okay if martini had a
famous actor play her in a movie who
would she pick
oh my god tree
oh who or what gets under martini's
fur
oh anybody taking her treats or bones
that she decides to hide because she
hides them for a reason and then she'll
go back and they're gone
because they're in your personal space
but that shouldn't matter because she
put them there
i understand what's martini's biggest
fear
stairs oh if martini could read what
would her favorite novel be
does everyone poops count
it does and my daughters love that book
too if martini could change
one thing about you what would it be
ugh my busy schedule
oh oh [ __ ] oh my god we run out of time
that's wonderful
thank you so much oh i love
you i love martini i love dickinson and
by the way i am going to be blasting
love myself
today and thinking about getting to
speak with you and how you turn me into
a giddy school girl when i'm around you
and thank you so much let it not be
another decade
before i get the pleasure of being in
your company again
it's so nice to see you thank you thank
you so much
thank you for being on the show today
haley steinfeld dickinson returns on
apple tv
today it premieres